you know challenging it was it was
actually I would say one of the harder'
games at one point that they definitely
adjusted so it's not so bad anymore
so it's a you know quick learning curve
there's there's quite a few like Y times
at least they'll be hidden under class
where you have to make a match from the
outside the door defeat the class that's
very special about that twenty different
kinds of blockers
get to the point with us pros on the
board and some other stuff so it's
really I think it's um it's developed
into one of the one of the policies at
this point you can see the graphics are
really nice got under 20 levels and
check it out and what I find interesting
is it's like I said it did start from
the very early thing it's cool to see
how they changed since to make it more
exciting and fun for players and I think
it really is a brand new type of format
so what do you think let us know leave a
comment below tell us what you think you
can do be a popular one
if you like graphics if you think it
would be the kind of game that you want
to see more they just recently released
the very early version of sky bright
saga which is another line with
privilege I think the mechanics are
played but make sure you subscribe to my
channel so that you can get videos like
this find out what's going on in the
gaming world and like the video another
helpful thanks
you